This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Across centuries, artists and writers have tried to make sense of the mysterious force that brings ideas to life. The ancient Greeks imagine the muse as a literal spirit, a whispering goddess who breathed inspiration into the poet's ear. Renaissance painters courted her through ritual and prayer, while romantic poets look for her in storms, mountain peaks, and moonlit walks. Now, psychological research is discovering that what the ancients call divine inspiration is really the brain at play.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。几个世纪以来，艺术家和作家们一直试图理解那种赋予创意以生命的神奇力量。古希腊人将缪斯想象成一种实实在在的精神，一位在诗人耳边低语、注入灵感的女神。文艺复兴时期的画家通过仪式和祈祷来寻求她的眷顾，而浪漫主义诗人则在风暴、山峰和月光下的漫步中寻找她的踪迹。现在，心理学研究发现，古人所说的神圣灵感，其实是大脑在“玩耍”。
When we are relaxed, taking a shower, folding laundry, staring out a window, our minds slip into a pattern of spontaneous association. Neurons fire across disparate brain regions, linking old memories with half-formed ideas. Then, suddenly, and insight bubbles up. It feels like a gift from the heavens,
当我们放松下来，洗澡、叠衣服或望着窗外发呆时，我们的思维会进入一种自发联想的模式。神经元在不同的大脑区域间放电，将旧记忆与尚未成形的想法连接起来。然后，灵感突然涌现。它感觉就像是来自天堂的礼物，
but it's really the product of our own unconscious minds. This week on Hidden Brain, and in a companion story on Hidden Brain Plus, the origins of creativity and how to find the muse within. When we think about how creative work unfolds, we usually imagine it happening in moments of intense focus, a painter standing before his canvas,
但实际上，它却是我们潜意识的产物。本周的《隐藏的大脑》，以及《隐藏的大脑 Plus》中的配套故事，将探讨创造力的起源，以及如何找到内心的缪斯。当我们思考创造性工作是如何展开时，我们通常会想象它发生在高度专注的时刻，比如画家站在画布前，
a scientist peering into who, her microscope. But research shows that many of our most original ideas do not appear when we are concentrating hard. They arrive when our minds wander, when we're driving, showering, or staring into space. Op Dykstra House is a psychologist who recently retired from Ratbout University Namaghan in the Netherlands. He studies the origins of inspiration and creativity. Op Dexter House, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you. Op, you're familiar with the story of Friedrich August Keckhule, a German chemist born in 1829. What was the great research project of his life?
或者科学家盯着显微镜。但研究表明，我们许多最具原创性的想法并非出现在我们高度集中注意力时。它们出现在我们思维漫游时，比如开车、洗澡或发呆的时候。阿普·戴克斯特豪斯是一位心理学家，最近从荷兰奈梅亨的拉德堡德大学退休。他研究灵感和创造力的起源。阿普·戴克斯特豪斯，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢。阿普，你很熟悉弗里德里希·奥古斯特·凯库勒的故事，他是一位出生于1829年的德国化学家。他一生中伟大的研究项目是什么？
Kekule was working on the structure of molecules that was in the 1860s what the most famous chemists did. And some of the structures were known by then. We knew what water looked like or oxygen. But Kekule was working on more complex molecules. So these complex molecules often were related to carbon and how carbon molecules took the form of long chains, right? Yeah, yeah, exactly. And he was, I think, at the time working on what they called benzene, which is part of crude oil. And he was working on it for quite a while.
凯库勒当时正在研究分子的结构，那是19世纪60年代最著名的化学家所做的事情。那时，一些结构已经为人所知。我们知道水或氧气是什么样子的。但凯库勒研究的是更复杂的分子。这些复杂的分子通常与碳有关，以及碳分子如何以长链的形式存在，对吧？是的，完全正确。当时他似乎正在研究所谓的苯，它是原油的一部分。他研究它已经有一段时间了。
He couldn't figure out the structure of that molecule. And at some point, he thought about it, he thought about it, and he thought about it even more. and then he dozed off in front of his fireplace, and he fell asleep. And in his dream, he suddenly saw a snake biting its own tail, and he woke up, startled, and he suddenly knew that benzene had the shape of a ring.
他一直无法弄清那个分子的结构。有一次，他反复思考，想了又想，想得更多。然后他在壁炉前打了个盹，睡着了。在梦中，他突然看到一条蛇咬住了自己的尾巴，他惊醒过来，突然意识到苯的形状是一个环。
So in other words, these carbon molecules had these long chains, but the insight that he got while he was sleeping was that this long chain in some way circled back on itself and formed a ring. Yeah, and that was exactly, in a dream. and that was at the time completely new. Nobody had thought about it. He must have been very startled to have woken up from this dream
换句话说，这些碳分子有长链，但他睡觉时得到的灵感是，这条长链以某种方式绕回自身，形成了一个环。是的，确实是在梦中。这在当时是全新的发现。没有人想到过这一点。他从这个梦中醒来时一定非常震惊，
with this dream of a snake and realized that in some ways it had solved his problem. He was shocked. Yeah, he was shocked himself. And of course also elated because he immediately realized that it was not just a dream, that it was the solution. He must have been euphoric as well.
带着这个关于蛇的梦，意识到它在某种程度上解决了他的问题。他很震惊。是的，他自己也很震惊。当然也很高兴，因为他立刻意识到这不仅仅是一个梦，而是解决方案。他一定也感到欣喜若狂。
So some years after that discovery, a French scientist and mathematician, Henri Poincaray, was working on a problem related to what are known as fusion functions. Again, like Keculet, he found himself stumped? Yeah, Puancaray did all kinds of different things. He was really almost a universal scientist, but one of the things he did was indeed Fuxian equations. There he worked on, I think, for seven or eight years already.
在那次发现几年后，法国科学家兼数学家亨利·庞加莱正在研究一个与所谓的富克斯函数相关的问题。和凯库勒一样，他也遇到了瓶颈？是的，庞加莱做了各种各样的事情。他几乎是一位全能科学家，但他所做的事情之一确实是富克斯方程。我想他已经在那里研究了七八年了。
And he made some progress, but there was a big puzzle that he couldn't solve. Then at a day where he wasn't going to work, he was in the countryside doing something completely different, and he stepped on a bus. And the moment he stepped on the bus, almost the exact millisecond, he saw the solution.
他取得了一些进展，但有一个巨大的难题他无法解决。后来有一天，他不去工作，在乡下做着完全不同的事情，他上了一辆公共汽车。就在他踏上踏板的那一刻，几乎就在那一毫秒，他看到了解决方案。
He just knew it. And it felt like it came out of nowhere, but he knew the solution. One of the striking things was, in both the Kekewley story as well as in the Poangare story, the answer seemed to come almost effortlessly. Yeah.
他就是知道了。感觉它好像凭空出现，但他确实知道了答案。令人惊讶的一点是，在凯库勒和庞加莱的故事中，答案似乎都来得毫不费力。是的。
If you have one of those sudden flashes of insight or inspiration, it feels like it comes out of nowhere. And for a long time, people believe these insights came from God. Or in the old Greek days, the time of the old Greek philosophers, they thought it came from muses, the nine goddesses. And Pueng Coray was probably the first one who explicitly said, you know, it came from your brain. But it's in an area of your brain where you're,
如果你有那种突如其来的灵感或启发，它感觉就像是凭空出现的。很长一段时间里，人们相信这些灵感来自上帝。或者在古希腊时代，古希腊哲学家们认为它来自缪斯，那九位女神。庞加莱可能是第一个明确指出它来自大脑的人。但它位于你大脑中一个你，
just can't reach. And at a certain point, you have this sudden flash of insight. Henri Poincaray wrote about his epiphany, and it's, I think, instructive to listen to his words directly. He describes getting on this bus, and he writes, we entered an omnibus to go someplace or other. At the moment when I put my foot on the step, the idea came to me without anything in my former thoughts seeming to have paved the way for it, that the transformations I had used to define the fusion functions were identical with those of Euclidean geometry. I did not verify the idea. I should not have had time. As upon taking my seat in the omnibus, I went on with a conversation already commenced, but I felt a perfect certainty. So this is another
根本无法触及的区域。在某个时刻，你突然有了灵感。亨利·庞加莱写下了他的顿悟，我认为听听他的原话很有启发。他描述了上这辆公共汽车的过程，他写道：“我们上了一辆公共汽车去某个地方。就在我把脚踏上踏板的那一刻，这个想法出现了，没有任何我之前的想法似乎为它铺平了道路，即我用来定义富克斯函数的变换与欧几里得几何的变换是相同的。我没有验证这个想法。我没有时间。当我坐在公共汽车上时，我继续着刚才开始的谈话，但我感到一种完美的确定性。”所以这是这些顿悟的另一个，
quality of these epiphanies, which is that they not only come to us out of the blue, but when they come to us, we feel like we have absolute certainty that they must be right. Yeah, the sudden burst of inspirations are wonderful in different ways. One of them is indeed, if scientists have these ideas, yes, they feel absolutely right. And some people describe these moments of insight basically as love. They give you a lot of energy at the same time. And the third thing is that it feels almost magical. And that's why you feel forced to do something with it. You can't have a wonderful moment of insight and then say, oh, I'm going to ignore it for the forthcoming three days, I just, you know, I'm now going to do something completely different. That's impossible.
特质，那就是它们不仅凭空而来，而且当它们到来时，我们感到绝对确定它们一定是正确的。是的，这种突如其来的灵感在不同方面都很奇妙。其中之一确实是，如果科学家有了这些想法，是的，他们感到绝对正确。有些人基本上把这些灵感时刻描述为爱。它们同时给你很多能量。第三点是，它感觉几乎是神奇的。这就是为什么你觉得必须用它做点什么。你不能拥有一个美妙的灵感时刻，然后说，哦，接下来的三天我要忽略它，我只是，你知道，我现在要去做完全不同的事情。那是不可能的。
I understand that after this experience, Henri Poincari changed the way he worked. How so, up, what did he do? Well, Poincorre said, okay, if my unconscious works on mathematical problems, I should give it time. So what he started to do is he worked only four hours a day, two in the morning and two in the afternoon, at least in a conscious way. He worked in a conscious way four hours a day, and the rest of the day he assumed that his unconscious would work on the problems he was working on.
我了解到在那次经历之后，亨利·庞加莱改变了他的工作方式。怎么改变的，阿普，他做了什么？嗯，庞加莱说，好吧，如果我的潜意识在处理数学问题，我应该给它时间。所以他开始做的是，他每天只工作四个小时，早上两个小时，下午两个小时，至少在意识层面是这样。他每天有意识地工作四个小时，而一天中剩下的时间，他假设他的潜意识会在处理他正在研究的问题。
You tell a wonderful story involving the scientist Lawrence Bragg. Who was he up, and how did he spend his time? Lawrence Bragg was the youngest Nobel Prize winner ever, and I think he still is. He was 25 or 26 when he won the Nobel Prize. in physics. And what he did, he had one day a week where he chose to go gardening
你讲了一个涉及科学家劳伦斯·布拉格的精彩故事。他是谁，阿普，他是怎么度过他的时间的？劳伦斯·布拉格是有史以来最年轻的诺贝尔奖得主，我想他现在依然是。他获得诺贝尔物理学奖时只有25或26岁。他所做的是，他每周有一天选择去园艺，
rather than working in his lab. And the assumption, of course, is that he was working on his scientific problems unconsciously. And what is, especially in music, about the story, is that he was dending the garden of an elderly lady in London who didn't even know
而不是在实验室工作。当然，假设是他潜意识里在处理他的科学问题。这个故事特别有趣的地方在于，他当时正在为伦敦一位老太太打理花园，她甚至不知道，
that she had this very famous gardener So until, and it lasted until one of her friends came, and she stood there in front of the window looking outside in the garden. And she said, my dear, do you realize that the Nobel laureate Sir Lawrence Bragg is actually pruning your hedges? Before that, she didn't have an idea that she probably had the most famous gardener. But yeah, he really believed in the importance of sometimes doing something completely different. For centuries, we've been told stories about inspiration as something that visits us,
她有一位这么著名的园丁。直到她的一个朋友来了，站在窗前看着外面的花园。她说：“亲爱的，你意识到诺贝尔奖得主劳伦斯·布拉格爵士正在修剪你的树篱吗？”在此之前，她根本不知道她可能拥有最著名的园丁。但是的，他确实相信有时做些完全不同的事情的重要性。几个世纪以来，我们一直听到关于灵感的传说，说它是某种造访我们的东西，
a spark from the gods, a sudden gust of grace. Science is now finding that the spark is already burning inside us, and there are things we can do to give the spark oxygen. When we come back, how the brain comes up with original ideas. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. I remember reading a poem by Percy Bixie Berm. Shelley many years ago. In hymn to intellectual beauty, which is partly about the nature of
来自神的火花，一阵突如其来的恩典。科学现在发现，火花已经在我们体内燃烧，我们可以做一些事情来为火花提供氧气。回来后，我们将探讨大脑是如何产生原创想法的。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我记得多年前读过珀西·比希·雪莱的一首诗。在《赞美理智之美》中，这首诗部分是关于，
inspiration, he writes, sudden, thy shadow fell on me, I shrieked and clasped my hands in ecstasy. This idea that inspiration comes out of nowhere, that it is unpredictable, untamable, this is a very old idea. Op Dykstrahaus is a psychologist who studies the science of inspiration and creativity. Bob, one of the most intriguing ideas in your work is that you have found that the brain has the capacity to continue to work on problems, even when our attention has turned to other things. How does this happen? Most of us think that we focus on problems and then we solve those problems because we're focused on them. I once wrote a children's book about psychology, and I compared thinking to a whale, you know, a whale sometimes surfaces.
灵感的本质，他写道：“突然，你的阴影落在我身上，我尖叫着，狂喜地紧握双手。”这种灵感凭空而来，不可预测、无法驯服的想法，是一个非常古老的想法。阿普·戴克斯特豪斯是一位研究灵感和创造力科学的心理学家。阿普，你工作中一个最引人入胜的想法是，你发现大脑有能力在我们的注意力转向其他事情时继续处理问题。这是怎么发生的？我们大多数人认为我们专注于问题，然后因为我们专注于它们而解决了这些问题。我曾经写过一本关于心理学的儿童读物，我把思考比作鲸鱼，你知道，鲸鱼有时会浮出水面，
but most of the time a whale is actually underwater and it still continues to swim. And thinking is like that. If we set ourselves important goals or if we work on something that we find very important, we think about it when we pay attention to it, but also when we don't pay attention to it, when we're doing something completely different, like watching a movie, our brain continues to work on that important problem. For things such as inspiration and creativity and problem solving,
但大多数时候，鲸鱼实际上是在水下，它仍然在继续游泳。思考也是如此。如果我们为自己设定了重要的目标，或者如果我们正在研究我们认为非常重要的事情，当我们关注它时我们会思考它，但当我们不关注它时，当我们做完全不同的事情，比如看电影时，我们的大脑也会继续处理那个重要的问题。对于灵感、创造力和解决问题等事情，
this is extremely important. In some ways, I think this dovetails really nicely with a central idea of the Hidden Brain Project, which is that even as we feel like everything that happens in our minds happens at a conscious level, significant amounts of what happened in our minds, in fact, are hidden from us. That's the origin of the term hidden brain.
这极其重要。在某种程度上，我认为这与《隐藏的大脑》项目的核心思想非常吻合，即即使我们觉得大脑中发生的一切都发生在意识层面，但实际上我们大脑中发生的很大一部分对我们来说是隐藏的。这就是“隐藏的大脑”这个术语的起源。
And really what you're saying is that the same thing happens with creativity, that in some ways left to itself, that there are things that happen under the surface that we're not aware of. And I love that metaphor of the whale that spends most of its time underwater and then surfaces now and again to take a breath of air. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I think the first episode of Hidden Brain I ever listened to was simply because of the title, because of the name Hidden Brain, I thought, this is what I'm working on. Yeah, it's very much comparable.
你真正想说的是，创造力也发生了同样的事情，在某种程度上，如果任其发展，有些事情会在表面之下发生，而我们并没有意识到。我喜欢那个鲸鱼的隐喻，它大部分时间都在水下，然后不时浮出水面呼吸空气。是的，是的，是的。我想我听过的第一集《隐藏的大脑》仅仅是因为标题，因为“隐藏的大脑”这个名字，我想，这就是我正在研究的东西。是的，这非常有可比性。
Researchers using brain scanning equipment have monitored the brain while it shifts from task to task. What have such studies discovered about how the brain works up? Well, when we started to study the idea that people think unconsciously, that's the way we call it, what we did is we gave information about four different apartments in the city of Amsterdam. This was at the time where I was working at the University of Amsterdam. We gave students information about four different departments, and we made sure that one apartment was more attractive than the others. But they got a lot of information.
研究人员使用脑部扫描设备在任务切换时监测大脑。这些研究发现了大脑是如何工作的，阿普？嗯，当我们开始研究人们潜意识思考的想法时，我们就是这样称呼它的，我们所做的是，我们提供了关于阿姆斯特丹市四个不同公寓的信息。那是我在阿姆斯特丹大学工作的时候。我们给学生提供了关于四个不同公寓的信息，我们确保其中一个公寓比其他公寓更具吸引力。但他们得到了很多信息。
It wasn't all that easy to figure it out. And we said to these participants, choose the best department. And we had two groups. The first group simply read the information and they chose. And the second group, they read the information. We told them to choose later on. And first they were distracted with a word puzzle, something simple. And then just a few minutes later, they were asked their favorite department.
弄清楚这一点并不容易。我们对这些参与者说，选择最好的公寓。我们有两组。第一组只是阅读了信息，然后他们做出了选择。第二组，他们阅读了信息。我们告诉他们稍后再选择。首先，他们被一个字谜游戏分散了注意力，一些简单的事情。然后就在几分钟后，他们被问及他们最喜欢的公寓。
And they performed much better than the other group. So if you give yourself a couple of minutes to unconsciously think about something, you make better decisions. And we added a third group where we said to, after people read the information about the apartments, we said, well, you can forget about the information of the apartments. We're not going to ask you anything about it. And then they still got the word puzzles. And then we, it's a bit mean, but we said, okay, sorry, but we do want you to choose the best apartment.
他们的表现比另一组好得多。所以，如果你给自己几分钟时间潜意识地思考某件事，你会做出更好的决定。我们增加了一个第三组，我们对他们说，在人们阅读了关于公寓的信息后，我们说，好吧，你可以忘记关于公寓的信息。我们不会问你任何关于它的问题。然后他们仍然做了字谜游戏。然后我们，这有点刻薄，但我们说，好吧，抱歉，但我们确实希望你选择最好的公寓。
And they failed again. And in the second stage, other researchers show that when people read the information about the apartments, and certain brain areas become active. They're thinking about the apartments. And then when you set a goal to later make a choice and you do these word puzzles, then the brain area still continue to work on the apartments. When you tell people you can forget about the information of the apartments,
他们又失败了。在第二阶段，其他研究人员表明，当人们阅读关于公寓的信息时，某些大脑区域变得活跃。他们在思考公寓。然后，当你设定一个目标稍后做出选择，并且你做这些字谜游戏时，大脑区域仍然会继续处理公寓。当你告诉人们你可以忘记关于公寓的信息，
we're not going to use it. The brain activity in that particular area stops. So this is fascinating. What you're finding is that when you tell people to focus on a problem and to focus exclusively on the problem and come up with an answer. In some ways, they do worse than people who are asked first to focus on the problem and then do something else that's a little distracting and then return to the problem.
我们不会使用它。该特定区域的大脑活动停止了。所以这很迷人。你的发现是，当你告诉人们专注于一个问题，并专门专注于这个问题并得出一个答案时。在某种程度上，他们的表现比那些被要求先专注于问题，然后做一些稍微分散注意力的事情，然后再回到问题的人要差。
But the people who are told to focus on the problem and then forget about the problem, they in fact do not do as well as the people who are given the distraction task. So in other words, focusing on something and being distracted for a little while is a great way to get your unconscious mind to continue to think about the problem. Yeah, exactly. And the only thing you need is motivation. or you set yourself a goal. So let's say you talk to your partner and you think about,
但是那些被告知专注于问题然后忘记问题的人，实际上表现不如那些被给予分散注意力任务的人。换句话说，专注于某事并分心一会儿，是让你的潜意识继续思考问题的好方法。是的，完全正确。你唯一需要的就是动力。或者你为自己设定一个目标。所以，假设你和你的伴侣交谈，你想到，
it's now Thursday, you tell yourself, okay, we're going to make a city trip, but you have to decide which city you want to visit. And then you say, okay, we're not going to talk about it for too much any longer, but let's say on Sunday evening when we have dinner together, we're going to make a decision. From that moment on, you give your unconscious mind or your hidden brain, you give a job to do, and it will think, it will think about it unconsciously for the two, three days until Sunday.
现在是星期四，你告诉自己，好吧，我们要去城市旅行，但你必须决定你想去哪个城市。然后你说，好吧，我们不再谈论它了，但假设在星期天晚上我们一起吃晚饭时，我们要做出决定。从那一刻起，你给了你的潜意识或你的隐藏大脑一个任务，它会思考，它会潜意识地思考它两三天，直到星期天。
And you increase the chances that you actually know what you want by Sunday. Now, there are some goals that, in fact, are best left to the conscious mind. So if you're evaluating potential mortgages, for example, or you're consulting a manual to fix an appliance, there are domains where, in fact, thinking about the problem is better than not thinking about the problem. Yeah. You can actually distinguish between three categories. There are things that our unconscious will always think about,
你增加了你在星期天真正知道自己想要什么的几率。现在，有些目标实际上最好留给意识去处理。所以，如果你正在评估潜在的抵押贷款，或者你正在查阅手册来修理电器，在某些领域，实际上思考问题比不思考问题更好。是的。你实际上可以区分三个类别。有些事情我们的潜意识总是会思考，
and these have to do with basic routines or also with survival, or things that are very much based on emotions. You can think about love. You know, these are things that, you know, your mind, or your minds of most people anyway, will work on naturally. Then there's things, creativity, inspiration, scientific problems, for instance, where your mind can think about if you set yourself goals, but it's not, it doesn't do so naturally.
这些与基本常规或生存有关，或者与情绪密切相关。你可以想想爱。你知道，这些是你的大脑，或者大多数人的大脑，自然会处理的事情。然后是创造力、灵感、科学问题等，如果你为自己设定目标，你的大脑可以思考，但它不会自然地这样做。
You have to want it. You have to set yourself goals. And then there's a third category, and that's where you are referring to. These are like mortgages or pension plans or from the perspective of your unconscious. This is just a lot of modern nonsense that it's not going to, it's not going to think about, you know. So, yeah, if you have to make decisions. that domain, and of course in modern life, we sometimes have to make such decisions.
你必须想要它。你必须为自己设定目标。然后是第三类，这就是你所指的。这些就像抵押贷款或养老金计划，或者从你潜意识的角度来看。这只是很多现代废话，它不会去思考，你知道。所以，是的，如果你必须做出决定。那个领域，当然在现代生活中，我们有时必须做出这样的决定。
You have to do it with a lot of conscious thought. Yeah. The unconscious is not going to do it for you. Let's take a look at some of the qualities of unconscious thinking that can make it so generative. You say that unconscious thought processes are capacious and can hold more information than conscious thoughts can hold. Why would this be the case? it's simply a consequence of the of the enormous capacity of our brain and a rather limited capacity of consciousness consciousness is one wonderful quality it's very precise you know i could ask you what's 14 times 17 and you can use a calculator but if you don't use a calculator your consciousness can solve this
你必须通过大量的有意识的思考来完成它。是的。潜意识不会为你做这件事。让我们看看潜意识思维的一些特质，这些特质使它如此具有生成性。你说潜意识思维过程容量大，能容纳比有意识思维更多的信息。为什么会这样？这仅仅是大脑巨大容量和意识相当有限的容量的结果。意识有一种奇妙的特质，它非常精确，你知道，我可以问你14乘以17等于多少，你可以使用计算器，但如果你不使用计算器，你的意识可以在几秒钟内解决这个问题。
within a few seconds the unconscious will never solve you can you can solve word puzzles for six weeks. You still don't know the answer. So that's the wonderful thing about consciousness. But the unconscious has this vast capacity where, let's say, you have to make a decision to buy a house or not, or even to choose between various houses. The amount of information you have to process in order to reach such a decision is really enormous. And this is a, it turns out this is something that the unconscious is much better at than consciousness. in some ways I think what you're saying is that the conscious mind functions almost like a spotlight. It basically focuses on something and is able to illuminate that thing very well.
潜意识永远不会解决。你可以做六周的字谜游戏。你仍然不知道答案。这就是意识的奇妙之处。但潜意识拥有这种巨大的容量，假设你必须做出买房的决定，或者甚至在各种房子之间做出选择。为了做出这样的决定，你必须处理的信息量确实是巨大的。事实证明，这是潜意识比意识做得好得多的事情。在某种程度上，我认为你想说的是，意识就像一个聚光灯。它基本上专注于某件事，并且能够很好地照亮那件事。
And the unconscious mind has perhaps a wider aperture. It basically it's a floodlight that is covering a much larger terrain. That's exactly what it is. Yeah, that's exactly what it is. And that also makes the unconscious more wild and associative. a way and in a sense also more creative you know if you if you think about something unconsciously you come up with things sometimes at least that are quite unexpected and and yeah wild and consciousness on the other hand yeah exactly it's a spotlight it's very it's very precise it's not the most adventurous thinking usually but it's it's precise you also say that unconscious thought processes
而潜意识可能有一个更宽的光圈。它基本上是一个覆盖更大区域的泛光灯。这正是它的样子。是的，这正是它的样子。这也使潜意识更狂野、更具联想性。在某种意义上，也更具创造力。你知道，如果你潜意识地思考某件事，你有时会想出一些非常出乎意料的事情，而且，是的，狂野。而意识，另一方面，是的，完全正确，它是一个聚光灯。它非常精确，通常不是最冒险的思维，但它很精确。你也说潜意识思维过程
can draw on the deep recesses of our memory um Talk about how such memories might enrich our creativity up. Well, I think what happens is if you think unconsciously, yes, it's almost unlimited when it comes to the information your unconscious uses, and it can involve basically everything, you know, including childhood memories. And I think that's one of the reasons that if scientists or artists, if they engage their unconscious, they are much more creative. They come up with things that are,
可以利用我们记忆的深处。谈谈这些记忆如何丰富我们的创造力，阿普。嗯，我认为发生的事情是，如果你潜意识地思考，是的，当涉及到你的潜意识使用的信息时，它几乎是无限的，它可以基本上包含一切，你知道，包括童年记忆。我认为这就是为什么如果科学家或艺术家，如果他们调动他们的潜意识，他们会更有创造力。他们想出了一些，
very much unexpected. They associate things with each other that are usually not associated. You once ran an experiment where you asked people to write down the names of as many Dutch cities as they could think of that began with the letter A. Tell me about this experiment and what you found. That's an experiment where, yeah, I had two groups. So one group I simply asked, name as much cities and villages starting with the letter A. in the Netherlands and the other group.
非常出乎意料的事情。他们将通常不相关的事务联系在一起。你曾经做过一个实验，要求人们写下他们能想到的所有以字母A开头的荷兰城市的名字。告诉我这个实验以及你的发现。这是一个实验，是的，我有两组。所以一组我只是要求，列出尽可能多的以字母A开头的城市和村庄。在荷兰，另一组。
I said, you know, later I want you to list as many cities or villages with the letter A, but we're first going to do something else. And again, they engage in a few minutes in solving word puzzles with the idea that they would think unconsciously about these cities and villages with the letter A. And in terms of the sheer number they came up with, the number of villages and cities, it was the same between the two groups. but people who thought consciously came up with the more obvious choices like Amsterdam or the bigger cities. And people who thought unconsciously who were doing the word puzzles first,
我说，你知道，稍后我希望你列出尽可能多的以字母A开头的城市或村庄，但我们首先要做点别的。同样，他们花了几分钟时间解决字谜游戏，目的是让他们潜意识地思考这些以字母A开头的城市和村庄。就他们想出的绝对数量而言，村庄和城市的数量，两组之间是一样的。但有意识思考的人想出了更明显的选择，比如阿姆斯特丹或更大的城市。而潜意识思考的人，那些先做字谜游戏的人，
they came up with much more, you could say, unusual villages that some of them I had never even heard of. You also say that unconscious thought processes don't engage in concrete details as much as the essence or the gist of the information at hand. And in some ways, this is related to the spotlight versus floodlight metaphor, which is, again, you're trying, the unconscious mind is involved in, in sort of capturing the general feel of something, not necessarily the precise contours of many things. Yeah, the gist. That's probably the single best word to describe it. So if you think about something consciously, you focus on, also on a precise wording of information. if you think about something unconsciously, you look at the gist about what are the underlying traits.
他们想出了更多，你可以说，不寻常的村庄，其中一些我甚至从未听说过。你也说潜意识思维过程不像有意识思维那样关注具体的细节，而是关注手头信息的本质或要点。在某种程度上，这与聚光灯与泛光灯的隐喻有关，也就是说，潜意识思维参与的是捕捉某事的一般感觉，而不一定是许多事物的精确轮廓。是的，要点。这可能是描述它的最好的词。所以如果你有意识地思考某件事，你也会关注信息的精确措辞。如果你潜意识地思考某件事，你会看要点，关于潜在的特征是什么。
We have done experiments, for instance, where people have to form an impression of a hypothetical person. And you describe this person with all kinds of behavioral information. Like he likes to read newspapers. He's usually very late. And if you then later ask people what they remember about the person, You see that people who thought about it consciously have much better memory for the concrete information, reading the newspaper, for instance. And people who thought about it unconsciously, they have a feeling for what the underlying trade is.
例如，我们做过实验，人们必须对一个假设的人形成印象。你用各种行为信息来描述这个人。比如他喜欢读报纸。他通常很晚。如果你后来问人们他们记得关于这个人的什么，你会发现有意识思考的人对具体信息有更好的记忆，比如读报纸。而潜意识思考的人，他们对潜在的特质有感觉。
Is somebody forgetful or chaotic or maybe very intelligent? So the unconscious is more about the underlying meaning of things. In the example we talked about earlier with Henri Poincaray, you know, he talks about how the insubes, insight that he eventually had as he stepped onto this bus was an insight that allowed him to combine two ideas that, in fact, came from very different places. Talk about the idea that unconscious thought processes allow diverse ideas and experiences to mingle and combine in novel ways. Yeah, I think that is also one of the things unconscious thought is capable of doing. You know, for instance, even childhood memories can be part of such an unconscious thought process.
某人是健忘的、混乱的，还是非常聪明的？所以潜意识更多的是关于事物的潜在意义。在我们之前谈到的亨利·庞加莱的例子中，你知道，他谈到了当他踏上这辆公共汽车时他最终得到的灵感，是一个让他能够结合两个实际上来自非常不同地方的想法的灵感。谈谈潜意识思维过程允许不同的想法和经验以新颖的方式融合和结合的想法。是的，我认为这也是潜意识思维能够做到的事情之一。你知道，例如，即使是童年记忆也可以成为这种潜意识思维过程的一部分。
And it's almost like a definition of creativity that you combine things that aren't usually combined. And this is something our unconscious is known to be better at than if we think about something very consciously, very attentively. And in some ways, this then connects with the idea that unconscious thought processes are going to be associative. In other words, one thing leads to the next. And something from your childhood might intersect with something that happens in your workplace, which might intersect with something that you see in a sports game. whereas conscious thought processes are going to be more focused and convergent.
这几乎是创造力的定义，你结合了通常不结合的东西。这是我们的潜意识被认为比我们非常有意识、非常专注地思考某事时做得更好的事情。在某种程度上，这与潜意识思维是联想性的想法联系在一起。换句话说，一件事导致下一件事。你童年的一些事情可能会与你在工作场所发生的事情相交，这可能会与你在体育比赛中看到的事情相交。而有意识的思维过程会更专注和收敛。
And so you can see how conscious thinking can lead us very systematically down a path, whereas unconscious thinking, you know, it can lead us into, you know, dead ends and blind alleys, but it can also produce these unexpected connections that can lead to creativity. Yeah, first it leads you deeper into the mire,
所以你可以看到有意识的思维如何系统地引导我们走上一条路，而潜意识的思维，你知道，它可以引导我们进入，你知道，死胡同和盲巷，但它也可以产生这些意想不到的联系，从而导致创造力。是的，首先它引导你更深入地陷入泥潭，
as sometimes scientists say, but in the end, yeah, it often leads you to the real solutions. by using the most unusual associations and combinations, yeah. One remarkable capacity of unconscious thought processes is that they seem to generate seemingly complete and perfect answers. When Poincaray basically made his discovery, he said, you know, I felt a perfect certainty,
正如科学家有时所说，但最终，是的，它通常会引导你找到真正的解决方案。通过使用最不寻常的联想和组合，是的。潜意识思维过程的一个显著能力是，它们似乎能产生看似完整和完美的答案。当庞加莱基本上有了他的发现时，他说，你知道，我感到一种完美的确定性，
and he says later when he got home, for conscience's sake, I verified the result. In other words, he said, I knew the result was correct already, but just to go through the motions, I had to verify it. Why would that be the case? Why would unconscious thought processes come up with more complete answers, do you think of? Well, we don't really know, and the unconscious doesn't do it all the time, unfortunately.
他后来写道，当他回到家时，为了良心起见，我验证了结果。换句话说，他说，我已经知道结果是正确的，但为了走过场，我必须验证它。为什么会这样？你认为为什么潜意识思维过程会得出更完整的答案，阿普？嗯，我们并不真正知道，不幸的是，潜意识并不总是这样做。
It only does so occasionally. But when your unconscious comes up with a solution to something, occasionally it's just perfect. There's no interference of consciousness. It's just sort of truth arriving in its purses. form and you see it in many many different areas not just in science and if you look at popular music what you see is that if you look at bands or musicians the song that that is written most rapidly is also the most famous and with poetry it's the same thing you know some of the best poems were written in five or ten minutes and Picasso when he painted he would
它只是偶尔这样做。但当你的潜意识想出某事的解决方案时，偶尔它是完美的。没有意识的干扰。它只是某种真理以其纯粹的形式到来。你在许多许多不同的领域都能看到它，不仅仅是在科学领域。如果你看看流行音乐，你会发现，如果你看看乐队或音乐家，写得最快的歌也是最著名的。对于诗歌，也是一样，你知道，一些最好的诗是在五到十分钟内写成的。毕加索在画画时，他会
immediately stop if he if he felt that he was thinking about it too much. He was thinking, Conce. It would just have to be, it would have to occur naturally to him. And if he didn't occur naturally anymore, he would just stop. So yeah, there's something about the unconscious that it can come up with something that is very pure, very beautiful. Unfortunately, not every day, but it occasionally happens. Yeah. You described the story of the singer and songwriter Suzanne Vega, who wrote a very famous song that also came to her in a flash. What song was a song? was this, describe what happened to her up?
如果他觉得他想得太多，他会立即停止。他在想，有意识地。它必须自然地发生在他身上。如果它不再自然发生，他就会停止。所以，是的，潜意识有一些东西，它可以想出非常纯粹、非常美丽的东西。不幸的是，不是每天，但它偶尔会发生。是的。你描述了歌手兼词曲作者苏珊·维加的故事，她写了一首非常著名的歌，也是突然出现在她脑海中的。那首歌是什么歌？发生了什么，阿普？
This is Luca. Yeah, her song, Luca. I remember watching a documentary about her on Dutch television, and she showed her interviewer the lyrics she wrote for Luca, and it was just a piece of paper that she showed. And she said, this is when I, you know, the first time I wrote it, and nothing was crossed out. It was just there.
这是《卢卡》。是的，她的歌《卢卡》。我记得在荷兰电视上看过一部关于她的纪录片，她向采访者展示了她为《卢卡》写的歌词，那只是一张纸。她说，这是当我，你知道，第一次写它的时候，没有任何东西被划掉。它就在那里。
She, the lyrics just basically appeared to her, she only had to write them down. And this is actually not too unusual. A lot of musicians have one or two of such songs, and they're usually their most famous. Amy MacDonald wrote, This is the Live in about 15 minutes. Now, the song, Luca is about child abuse.
她，歌词基本上只是出现在她脑海中，她只需要把它们写下来。这实际上并不太罕见。许多音乐家有一两首这样的歌，它们通常是他们最著名的歌。艾米·麦克唐纳在大约15分钟内写了《这是生活》。现在，这首歌《卢卡》是关于虐待儿童的。
It describes a story of a young boy who basically is being harmed, presumably by his caretakers. And Suzanne Vega later said that in some ways, the song was autobiographical, that she was writing about herself. And here again is an example of someone's musical abilities and talents intersecting with their own childhood experiences
它描述了一个小男孩的故事，他基本上受到了伤害，大概是他的看护人。苏珊·维加后来表示，在某种程度上，这首歌是自传性的，她在写她自己。这里又是一个人的音乐能力和天赋与她自己的童年经历相交的例子，
and coming up with something that almost feels complete from the get-go. Yeah, it's a wonderful example of, yeah, an idea that is suddenly there and it's beautiful and it's pure and it's, yeah, it's finished. You know, she didn't have to do much about it. I think it was both the lyrics and the music were there within minutes. Yeah, it's a wonderful example. of what a creative unconscious can come up with. I understand that volunteers were presented once with riddles or problems
并想出了一些从一开始就感觉完整的东西。是的，这是一个很好的例子，关于一个突然出现的想法，它是美丽的，它是纯粹的，它是，是的，它是完成的。你知道，她不需要做太多事情。我想歌词和音乐都在几分钟内就完成了。是的，这是一个很好的例子，关于创造性的潜意识能想出什么。我了解到志愿者曾经被展示过谜语或问题，
that could be solved either through analysis or by sudden insight. What kind of problems were these? And what was the outcome of the experiment up? This is a tradition in cognitive psychology in the 1980s where people wanted to see, they wanted to study inside problems. And one example is, I think it goes like this. So these are riddle. Every day, water lilies double the surface area they occupy.
这些问题可以通过分析或突然的灵感来解决。这些是什么样的问题？实验的结果是什么，阿普？这是20世纪80年代认知心理学的一个传统，当时人们想看看，他们想研究洞察力问题。一个例子是，我想它是这样的。所以这些是谜语。每天，睡莲覆盖的表面积都会翻倍。
And at the start of the summer, there's only one lily leaf in the lake. After 60 days, the entire water surface is covered. On which day was the lake half covered with water lilies? Now, if you hear such a riddle, your conscious mind is inclined to just say, okay, so you start with one lily, and then the next day there's two, and then the third day there's four, and then you, but this is not going to get you anywhere. And what you need is inside. You need this sudden flesh where you understand the riddle. And this is usually, this usually occurs to you only when you take a little distance first. maybe even, you know, go and take a walk or something.
在夏天开始时，湖里只有一片睡莲叶。60天后，整个水面都被覆盖了。湖泊在第几天被睡莲覆盖了一半？现在，如果你听到这样的谜语，你的意识倾向于只是说，好吧，所以你从一片睡莲开始，然后第二天有两片，然后第三天有四片，然后你，但这不会让你有任何进展。你需要洞察力。你需要这种突然的灵感，让你理解这个谜语。这通常，这通常只有在你先保持一点距离时才会发生。甚至，你知道，去散散步什么的。
And then you realize, well, okay, if after 60 days the lake is fully covered and the number of leaves doubles every day, then of course half covered means it's the day before the last day. It's on day 59. And if the right answer comes to you, it comes in a sort of a flash. It never comes when you approach it very analytically or consciously. One of the things I like about that puzzle up is that in some ways, it requires us to actually turn the problem on its head. So in other words, instead of starting from day one and saying,
然后你意识到，好吧，如果60天后湖泊被完全覆盖，而且叶子的数量每天翻倍，那么当然，覆盖一半意味着它是最后一天的前一天。是在第59天。如果正确的答案出现在你脑海中，它会以一种闪光的方式出现。当你非常分析或有意识地处理它时，它永远不会出现。关于那个谜题，我喜欢的一点是，阿普，在某种程度上，它要求我们实际上把问题颠倒过来。所以换句话说，与其从第一天开始说，
okay, day one, there's one, there's one, day two, there's two, and so forth, you actually start from the end, and you say, okay, day 60, the lake is full, and now working backwards, when was the lake half full? And in some ways, you're turning the problem on its head, and when you turn the problem on its head, the problem actually becomes easy. Yeah. And then understanding the problem by turning us on its head is already the solution, Because then once you know it, you know, it's actually incredibly simple.
好吧，第一天，有一片，第二天，有两片，以此类推，你实际上从最后开始，你说，好吧，第60天，湖泊满了，现在倒着推，湖泊什么时候是一半满的？在某种程度上，你把问题颠倒了，当你把问题颠倒时，问题实际上变得简单了。是的。然后通过把问题颠倒来理解问题已经是解决方案了，因为一旦你知道了，你知道，它实际上非常简单。
Yeah. Yeah. Unconscious thought processes are operating even when we are asleep, of course. You write about a study in which volunteers who had experienced REM sleep were able to better solve problems requiring divergent thinking. Tell me about this work. I think it started about 30 years ago where scientists discovered that during sleep, we engage in memory consolidates.
是的。是的。当然，即使在我们睡觉时，潜意识思维过程也在运作。你写了一项研究，其中经历过快速眼动睡眠的志愿者能够更好地解决需要发散性思维的问题。告诉我这项工作。我想它始于大约30年前，当时科学家发现，在睡眠期间，我们进行记忆巩固。
So this means actually if you learn something, then during REM sleep we consolidate this information so that the next day we have better memory. And then people started to do more and more experiments and also more complex experiments where in the evening participants in experiments would read quite complex information about the relationship of certain stimuli like A is always bigger than B and B is always bigger than C and C is always bigger than D. but in later experiments, they made this information quite complex. And during the night, people could sleep. Other people did this during the day, so they also had eight hours until they came back to the testing room, but they couldn't sleep. And it turns out that during REM sleep,
所以这意味着实际上如果你学习了什么，那么在快速眼动睡眠期间，我们会巩固这些信息，以便第二天我们有更好的记忆。然后人们开始做越来越多的实验，也做更复杂的实验，在晚上，实验参与者会阅读关于某些刺激之间关系的相当复杂的信息，比如A总是比B大，B总是比C大，C总是比D大。但在后来的实验中，他们使这些信息变得相当复杂。在晚上，人们可以睡觉。其他人白天做这个，所以他们也有八个小时直到他们回到测试室，但他们不能睡觉。事实证明，在快速眼动睡眠期间，
this is where people make these interesting connections and people start to understand these very complex relations between stimuli. So only the group that slept during the night in a normal way could solve these complicated problems. People who were woken up during their REM sleep couldn't, and people who studied this during the day and so didn't sleep, they couldn't solve these problems either.
这就是人们建立这些有趣联系的地方，人们开始理解刺激之间这些非常复杂的关系。因此，只有在夜间正常睡眠的群体才能解决这些复杂的问题。在快速眼动睡眠期间被叫醒的人无法解决，而白天学习且没有睡觉的人也无法解决这些问题。
Now, REM sleep has long been associated with dreaming, and I'm wondering in some ways if the process of dreaming is in fact a process of creativity, because unusual things get linked when we are dreaming. Yes, indeed. dream sleep is our, is basically our dream sleep, and it's long been known that it is indeed associated with creativity. KQ Le, of course, is a good example. We know that yesterday, probably the most famous song by the Beatles, the melody of yesterday was dreamt by Paul McCartney. He woke up in the
现在，快速眼动睡眠长期以来一直与做梦联系在一起，我有时在想，做梦的过程实际上是否就是一种创造力的过程，因为当我们做梦时，不寻常的事物会被联系在一起。是的，确实如此。梦境睡眠基本上就是我们的梦境睡眠，而且人们早就知道它确实与创造力有关。KQ Le 当然就是一个很好的例子。我们知道《Yesterday》，这可能是披头士乐队最著名的歌曲，其旋律就是保罗·麦卡特尼梦到的。他在
morning, and he played that melody that he had dreamt. But for weeks, he thought, you know, it must have been plagiarism. I must have heard it somewhere before, and that's why it reappears. in my dream. And then he and Lennon and the other fellow band members started to listen to other music, but they couldn't find it. And only after a few weeks, they realized, no, this is really something new.
早上醒来，弹奏了他梦到的那段旋律。但几周以来，他一直想，你知道，这一定是抄袭。我一定在什么地方听过它，这就是为什么它会出现在我的梦里。然后他和列侬以及乐队的其他成员开始听其他音乐，但他们找不到这首歌。几周后，他们才意识到，不，这确实是全新的东西。
And he dreamt up a melody. And in some ways up, this speaks to what parents and educators have been telling children and students for a long time. If you're studying something, you're studying a subject or learning a difficult concept, the sleep that you get is actually an essential portion of your learning process. Absolutely.
他梦到了一段旋律。在某种程度上，这印证了父母和教育工作者长期以来一直告诉孩子和学生的话。如果你正在学习某样东西，正在学习一门学科或一个困难的概念，你所获得的睡眠实际上是你学习过程中至关重要的一部分。绝对是这样。
Yeah. And I think the more research we do, the more we figure out how important it really is. I remember my grandmother telling me, and I think this is something universal, that if you have to make an important decision, you have to sleep on it, literally. You know, don't make a decision tonight. Go sleep. And then tomorrow morning, you know, if it still feels good, then maybe you should do it. And that's like a universal wisdom.
是的。而且我认为我们做的研究越多，我们就越能发现它到底有多重要。我记得我祖母告诉我，而且我认为这是一件普遍的事情，如果你必须做出一个重要的决定，你必须“睡一觉再决定”，字面意思就是这样。你知道，今晚不要做决定。去睡觉。然后明天早上，你知道，如果感觉仍然不错，那么也许你应该去做。这就像是一种普遍的智慧。
And I think maybe in the old days people thought it was useful because at least it made sure that you weren't hurrying yourself or you would put in too much pressure on yourself. But now we realize more and more that no, during our sleep, a lot of very useful things happen. There are higher cognitive processes going on while we sleep and especially while we dream. If the first step in understanding creativity is recognizing that the muse lives inside us,
我想也许在过去，人们认为这很有用，因为至少它能确保你不会匆忙行事，或者不会给自己施加太大的压力。但现在我们越来越意识到，不，在睡眠期间，很多非常有用的事情会发生。当我们睡觉时，尤其是在做梦时，会进行更高层次的认知过程。如果理解创造力的第一步是认识到缪斯女神住在我们内心，
the next step is learning how to invite her to make an appearance. We cannot order inspiration to appear, but we can create the conditions where it is most likely to materialize. When we come back, habits and practices to coax creative ideas from the quiet corners of our minds. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Have you had an experience of struggling with a problem only to have a good night's sleep
那么下一步就是学习如何邀请她现身。我们不能命令灵感出现，但我们可以创造最有可能让它实现的环境。当我们回来时，我们将探讨如何从我们思想的安静角落引出创造性想法的习惯和做法。你正在收听的是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。你是否有过这样的经历：为一个问题苦苦挣扎，却在睡了一个好觉之后
and then find the answer came easily to you? Have you struggled to untangle a naughty conflict in a relationship and then found during a calm walk in nature that the problem seemed to unknot itself? If you are willing to share a personal story about inspiration and creativity with the Hidden Brain audience, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone.
发现答案轻而易举地出现了？你是否曾努力理清一段关系中棘手的冲突，却在自然中平静地散步时发现问题似乎迎刃而解了？如果你愿意与《Hidden Brain》的听众分享一个关于灵感和创造力的个人故事，请找一个非常安静的房间，并在手机上录制一段语音备忘录。
Two or three minutes is plenty. Email the file to us at Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org using the subject line, Inspiration. Again, that email address is Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Psychologist Op Dykstrahaus is the author of Inspiration, where the best ideas come from. Op, in terms of creating the conditions that generate insight, there are other situations, of course, besides sleep,
两三分钟就足够了。请将文件通过电子邮件发送给我们，地址是 Feedback@Hiddenbrain.org，主题行请写“Inspiration”。再说一遍，电子邮件地址是 Feedback@Hiddenbrain.org。心理学家奥普·戴克斯特拉豪斯是《灵感：最好的想法来自哪里》一书的作者。奥普，就创造产生洞察力的条件而言，当然还有其他情况，除了睡眠之外，
where we also have this kind of generative thinking. The author J.K. Rowling says the idea for Harry Potter came to her while she was riding a train. Yeah, it's one of the more famous and wonderful stories. She was a writer already, but she hadn't written anything that, well, she hadn't written anything of note. Let's put it that way. And then she took the train from Manchester to London. And in the train compartment, it basically just hit her. The story goes that within about an hour or so, basically the entire Harry Potter story came to her with the most important persons, with the plot, the storyline, and she frantically wrote everything up.
我们也会有这种生成性思维。作家J.K.罗琳说，哈利·波特的灵感是在她坐火车时产生的。是的，这是更著名、更精彩的故事之一。她当时已经是一位作家，但她还没有写出什么，嗯，她还没有写出什么值得注意的作品。我们这么说吧。然后她坐火车从曼彻斯特去伦敦。在火车车厢里，灵感基本上就击中了她。故事是这样的，在大约一个小时左右的时间里，基本上整个哈利·波特的故事都浮现在她脑海中，包括最重要的人物、情节、故事情节，她疯狂地把一切都写了下来。
And, well, in the next 15 years, she had to work really hard to actually write all these seven novels. But the idea came, yeah, during a train ride. And it was, again, one of those examples of an idea that is both beautiful and pure. more or less finished at the same time. It came to her and it was all there. Yeah. And in some ways, I think this speaks to an idea that we referred to earlier where, you know, you gave students a task
而且，嗯，在接下来的15年里，她不得不非常努力地工作，才能真正写完这七部小说。但灵感确实是在火车旅行中产生的。而且，这又是那种既美丽又纯粹的想法的例子之一。差不多在同一时间就完成了。它来到她身边，一切都在那里。是的。在某种程度上，我认为这印证了我们之前提到的一个想法，你知道，你给学生一个任务，
and some students had to solve the task right away and some students were distracted and then they came back and a third group were told about the information by then instructed to forget the information. And you found that the students who had been distracted in fact did the best on the task. And we've had other guests on Hidden Brain who've talked about this idea that when it comes to our attention, there are things that
一些学生必须立即解决任务，一些学生被分散了注意力，然后他们回来了，第三组学生被告知了信息，然后被指示忘记这些信息。你发现那些被分散了注意力的学生实际上在任务中表现得最好。我们还有其他嘉宾在《Hidden Brain》上谈论过这个想法，即当涉及到我们的注意力时，有些事情是
our minds attend to that are, you know, harshly fascinating, which is, you know, you're in Times Square, for example, or you're at a sporting event, and there's a lot of stuff happening, and it takes up all of your mental space. But there are also experiences that we have that are quietly fascinating or softly fascinating, where we're walking in nature. So in other it's not like there's no stimulation coming in, but it's not hyper-stimulated. And riding a train is a little bit like that. It's softly stimulating because things are changing. The landscape is changing as the train is proceeding, but it's not changing so dramatically that it takes up all of your attention. And it seems like it's in those situations that the mind
我们的思想所关注的，你知道，是强烈吸引人的，也就是，你知道，你在时代广场，或者你在体育赛事现场，有很多事情在发生，它占据了你所有的心理空间。但我们也有一些经历是安静地吸引人或柔和地吸引人的，比如我们在自然中散步。所以换句话说，并不是没有刺激进入，但它不是过度刺激。坐火车有点像那样。它是柔和的刺激，因为事物在变化。随着火车的行进，风景在变化，但它并没有剧烈到占据你所有的注意力。似乎正是在这些情况下，思想
is able to wander and come up with creative ideas. Yeah, those moments are indeed the best. I studied the working habits of artists and scientists, And what occurred to me is that most of them, especially work in the morning. Some of them work more often than just in the morning. But the morning is usually the most productive time. We know that people are, the cognitive abilities are usually at their best between about one and a half and five hours after you wake up, although that's not true for everybody, but it's true for most people.
才能够漫游并产生创造性的想法。是的，那些时刻确实是最好的。我研究了艺术家和科学家的工作习惯，我意识到他们中的大多数人，尤其是工作在早上。有些人工作的频率不仅仅是在早上。但早上通常是最高效的时间。我们知道，人们的认知能力通常在醒来后一个半小时到五个小时之间处于最佳状态，尽管这对每个人来说不一定都正确，但对大多数人来说是正确的。
And then in the afternoon, what you see is that many, many of them walk. and walking is just one example of what you may call a lightly meditative state the same as the train ride jk k rowling's train ride there's a few more of those and yeah those are indeed the most productive activities when it comes to unconscious thought and i think there's two reasons one of them is that unconscious thought itself is working best under those conditions if you if you compare it with time square or to a situation where you are working very hard on something like a complex problem your unconscious thought is not working too well because too much capacity is taken by other processes and the second reason is that of course
然后在下午，你看到他们中的许多人会散步。散步只是你所谓的轻度冥想状态的一个例子，和火车旅行、J.K.罗琳的火车旅行一样，还有更多这样的例子，是的，当涉及到无意识思维时，这些确实是最高效的活动，我认为有两个原因，其中之一是无意识思维本身在这些条件下工作得最好，如果你把它与时代广场或你正在非常努力地处理复杂问题的情况进行比较，你的无意识思维工作得并不好，因为太多的容量被其他过程占据了，第二个原因是，当然
there has to be room there has to be space in consciousness for a good idea to land so if you're watching a very you know a very good movie you're engrossed in the movie so there's you're not going to get any good ideas at least not at that time and when you when you walk in nature Yeah, there's plenty of room in consciousness to, let's say, receive ideas from the unconscious, from your hidden brain. So you say that a goal that engages the unconscious and generates inside should also be intrinsically oriented up? What do you mean by this? Well, intrinsic motivation basically means that you're doing something that comes out of you, comes from the deeper regions of your brain or maybe metaphorically from your heart.
意识中必须有空间，必须有空间让一个好的想法落地，所以如果你正在看一部非常，你知道，非常好的电影，你沉浸在电影中，所以你不会得到任何好的想法，至少在那个时候不会，当你散步在自然中时，是的，意识中有足够的空间，比如说，接收来自无意识的、来自你隐藏大脑的想法。所以你说一个吸引无意识并产生洞察力的目标也应该在本质上是内在导向的？你这是什么意思？嗯，内在动机基本上意味着你正在做一些源于你自己的事情，来自你大脑更深层的区域，或者隐喻地说来自你的内心。
It's something you really like to do, as opposed to extrinsic motivation. These are goals that you want to achieve because of money or fame or some kind of external awards that you can win, for instance. A little bit of extrinsic motivation isn't necessarily bad, but if you want to last, if you want to persevere for a long time, you need intrinsic motivation. Extrinsic motivation dries up usually quite quickly. You tell the story of Marco Pierre White, who became the youngest chef to receive three Michelin stars. Paint a picture for me of how he came to accomplish this and what the result was of these accomplishments up. So Marco quit school when he was 16. And his father, who also was a cook, said, well, you know, okay, if you want to quit school, you can quit school, but you have to go to work.
这是你真正喜欢做的事情，而不是外在动机。这些是你因为金钱、名声或你可以赢得的某种外部奖励而想要实现的目标，例如。一点点外在动机不一定是坏事，但如果你想持久，如果你想长期坚持，你需要内在动机。外在动机通常干涸得很快。你讲述了马可·皮埃尔·怀特的故事，他是最年轻获得三颗米其林星的厨师。请为我描绘一下他是如何实现这一目标的，以及这些成就的结果是什么。所以马可16岁时退学了。他的父亲也是一名厨师，他说，好吧，你知道，好吧，如果你想退学，你可以退学，但你必须去工作。
And then he said, you know, why don't you go work in the kitchen? It was a working class family, no frills, just work in the kitchen. And Marco started to work in a professional kitchen and he said the first time I saw it, it was like stepping in a jewelry box. He loved it. He thought it was absolutely fantastic. And within two years, he was the pastry chef in one of the best restaurants in the north of England. And within a few years, he had his first Michelin star.
然后他说，你知道，你为什么不去厨房工作呢？那是一个工人阶级家庭，没有虚饰，只是在厨房工作。马可开始在专业厨房工作，他说第一次看到它时，就像走进了一个珠宝盒。他喜欢它。他认为这绝对太棒了。两年内，他就成为了英格兰北部最好的餐厅之一的糕点师。几年内，他就获得了他的第一颗米其林星。
And he was very much intrinsically motivated. He loved to cook. He was very creative, wonderful chef. And then a few years later, he had three Michelin stars. He was the most successful young chef. And then he continued for a while, and one day he just woke up, and he didn't like it anymore. And he realized that he had been too focused on extrinsic rewards,
他非常有内在动力。他热爱烹饪。他是一位非常有创造力、出色的厨师。几年后，他获得了三颗米其林星。他是最成功的年轻厨师。然后他继续了一段时间，有一天他醒来，他不再喜欢它了。他意识到他太专注于外在奖励，
like the three Michelin stars. And that gradually his intrinsic motivation, slept away through his fingers and his extrinsic motivation became more important. And actually what he did is he just stopped. He basically gave the three Michelin stars back to Michelin. He said, you can have them. I don't need them anymore.
比如那三颗米其林星。他的内在动力逐渐从指缝中溜走，而他的外在动力变得更加重要。实际上他所做的是他直接停止了。他基本上把三颗米其林星还给了米其林。他说，你们拿走吧。我不再需要它们了。
He later in the interviews, he said the problem was also that up until he had these three stars, he loved cooking and he did everything he could to become a better chef. he wanted to improve himself, he wanted to challenge himself. And then he had these three Michelin stars. And the only thing you can do then is lose them again. So he was, he started to cook in order to not make any mistakes, which is a completely different way of, you know, doing things. And he, he lost his interest. He didn't like it anymore. So in some ways, this dovetails with work by the psychologist Ed D.C. and others that show that intrinsic motivation and
他后来在采访中说，问题还在于，在他获得这三颗星之前，他热爱烹饪，他尽其所能成为一名更好的厨师。他想提升自己，他想挑战自己。然后他获得了这三颗米其林星。而你唯一能做的就是再次失去它们。所以他开始烹饪是为了不犯任何错误，这是一种完全不同的做事方式。而且他失去了兴趣。他不再喜欢它了。所以从某种程度上说，这与心理学家爱德华·德西等人的工作相吻合，他们表明内在动机和
and extrinsic motivation are really these separate forces that live inside our minds and that extrinsic motivations are fine. There's nothing wrong with them, but they do have this tendency to slowly erode our intrinsic motivation. So in one of his more famous studies, if I remember this correctly, he went up to people who were doing some activity like solving crossword puzzles, and they were doing this activity on their own because they enjoyed doing it. And he then offered to pay them a small amount of money for each time
外在动机确实是存在于我们思想中的这些独立力量，外在动机没问题。它们没什么错，但它们确实有这种倾向，会慢慢侵蚀我们的内在动机。所以在他最著名的研究之一中，如果我没记错的话，他走到那些正在做一些活动（如解填字游戏）的人面前，他们自己做这项活动是因为他们喜欢做。然后他提出为他们每次
they finished a crossword puzzle. They paid them a dollar for every crossword puzzle they finished. And of course, you would think, well, this is going to increase their motivation to do crossword puzzles because they were doing them anyway, and now they're getting paid for doing them. But what he found was over time, the volunteer stopped doing the crossword puzzles unless they received the dollar. So in other words, the intrinsic motivation started to crowd out the intrinsic motivation, which is exactly what you are describing in the story with Marco Pier White.
完成一个填字游戏支付少量金钱。他们每完成一个填字游戏就支付一美元。当然，你会想，好吧，这会增加他们做填字游戏的动力，因为他们本来就在做，现在他们因为做这些而得到报酬。但他发现，随着时间的推移，志愿者除非收到那一美元，否则就不再做填字游戏了。换句话说，外在动机开始排挤内在动机，这正是你在马可·皮埃尔·怀特的故事中所描述的。
Yeah, exactly. And there's other examples. Even studies with children, you know, you ask them to make drawings. And this is what most children naturally love to do. And then you start to pay them or give them some other kind of reward. And they actually start to like it less. Yeah, the big problem with extrinsic motivation is not the extrinsic motivation itself, but it's the eroding, as you said, of the intrinsic motivation.
是的，完全正确。还有其他例子。即使是针对儿童的研究，你知道，你让他们画画。这是大多数孩子天生喜欢做的事情。然后你开始付钱给他们或给他们其他形式的奖励。他们实际上开始不那么喜欢它了。是的，外在动机的最大问题不是外在动机本身，而是正如你所说，对内在动机的侵蚀。
You know, it's like a cuckoo in the nest, you know. It pushes the other eggs out. I understand that you yourself had an experience in Ecuador some years ago that generated a moment of inspiration for you. Tell me what happened up. I wanted to write a book about creativity. And after about a year, I gave up because I liked the topic, but I didn't have a good idea of what the book would be. It was all still very vague. And then about three, four years later, I tried again, and again, I failed.
你知道，这就像巢里的杜鹃，你知道。它把其他的蛋挤了出去。我了解到你自己几年前在厄瓜多尔有过一次经历，为你产生了一个灵感的时刻。告诉我发生了什么。我想写一本关于创造力的书。大约一年后，我放弃了，因为我喜欢这个主题，但我对这本书会是什么样子没有一个好的想法。一切仍然非常模糊。然后大约三四年后，我再次尝试，结果又失败了。
And then I was in Ecuador, in Keith, the capital and there are four or five very old churches and convents in the old town and and it suddenly dawned on me how amazing that was you imagine it's 16th century you're on a boat for many many months and then you land on the shore of Ecuador and then with a group of of people you you go into this crazy jungle and you walk for a couple of weeks until you reach a mountain range and then you climb up to 8,000 feet. Your leader says, let's make a couple churches here.
然后我在厄瓜多尔，在首都基多，老城区有四五座非常古老的教堂和修道院，我突然意识到那是多么令人惊叹。你想象一下，那是16世纪，你在船上待了许多许多个月，然后你降落在厄瓜多尔的海岸上，然后和一群人一起，你走进这片疯狂的丛林，你走了几个星期，直到你到达一个山脉，然后你爬到8000英尺高。你的领队说，我们在这里建几座教堂吧。
What these colonialists did, the first thing they did when they arrived there is built four or five of these huge churches that are obviously still standing there. They're beautiful. And then that's when it dawned on me that the book shouldn't be about creativity. It should be about inspiration. So for me, it was a very important moment, yeah. You're clearly a fan of the Beatles because the Beatles have come up several times in our conversation. And you say that John Lennon and Paul McCartney had an unusual way of selecting the songs that they felt were worth keeping.
这些殖民者所做的，他们到达那里的第一件事就是建造了四五座这些巨大的教堂，它们显然仍然矗立在那里。它们很美。然后就在那时我意识到，这本书不应该关于创造力。它应该关于灵感。所以对我来说，这是一个非常重要的时刻，是的。你显然是披头士乐队的粉丝，因为披头士乐队在我们的谈话中多次出现。你说约翰·列侬和保罗·麦卡特尼有一种不寻常的方式来选择他们认为值得保留的歌曲。
They generated, of course, many melodies and lyrics, but didn't always finish all of them or publish all of them. What was their process up? They would jam in their studio and just come up with new songs all the time. but they didn't have any recording equipment at the time. So they basically had to memorize what they did. And then at some point, they just realized that, okay, if we play something in the afternoon, maybe we remember it the next morning, and then it's probably good. And if we don't remember it the next morning, well, fine, because it's probably not good enough anyway.
他们当然创作了许多旋律和歌词，但并不总是完成所有这些或发表所有这些。他们的过程是什么？他们会在工作室里即兴创作，一直想出新歌。但他们当时没有任何录音设备。所以他们基本上必须记住他们所做的事情。然后在某个时候，他们只是意识到，好吧，如果我们在下午演奏一些东西，也许我们第二天早上还记得它，那么它可能就是好的。如果我们第二天早上不记得它，好吧，没关系，因为它可能本来就不够好。
So they had a very natural selection process in coming up with their songs. You know, it's striking to me up as we are talking today, I'm realizing that in so many different ways, we are not in our daily lives, in our modern lives, really allowing the unconscious to flourish. You know, we write down every single thought we have. We are so focused on our emails and our work. We're basically very directed in what we are trying to finish. We have goals and we say, okay, I'm going to work on this goal very closely.
所以他们在创作歌曲时有一个非常自然的筛选过程。你知道，奥普，今天我们谈话时我感到很震惊，我意识到在许多不同的方面，我们在日常生活中，在现代生活中，并没有真正让无意识蓬勃发展。你知道，我们写下我们拥有的每一个想法。我们太专注于我们的电子邮件和我们的工作。我们基本上在我们试图完成的事情上非常有针对性。我们有目标，我们说，好吧，我要非常密切地致力于这个目标。
And taking a day off every week to go and garden would be a waste of time. Talk about the ways in which our modern world, in some ways, is working against the capacity. of our unconscious minds to help us be creative? I think that basically all this modern technology, it's highly useful in some ways, but it also clutters our mind. These days you need to remember a password when you want to order something from your local butcher.
每周休一天假去园艺会是浪费时间。谈谈我们的现代世界在某些方面是如何违背我们无意识思维帮助我们发挥创造力的能力的？我认为基本上所有这些现代技术，在某些方面非常有用，但它也使我们的思想混乱。这些天，当你想要从当地屠夫那里订购东西时，你需要记住一个密码。
It's pretty crazy these days. And you have to almost literally clean your mind, and you do this by things such as walking, by doing other things. and this frees up your unconscious mind again for things that you actually want to achieve for useful things. Email, let's face it, email these days,
这些天真是太疯狂了。你几乎必须字面意思上清理你的思想，你通过散步、做其他事情来做到这一点。这再次为你想实际实现的事情、为有用的事情释放了你的无意识思维。电子邮件，让我们面对现实吧，电子邮件这些天，
is a to-do list where other people put things on. If you see it in this way, it's easier to sometimes just say, sorry, now I'm going to choose for myself. Inspiration often feels like a bolt of lightning. As we've seen, there are a number of things we can do to make our minds hospitable places for creativity. In our companion story to this episode, available exclusively to subscribers to Hidden Brain Plus,
是一个待办事项列表，其他人把事情放在上面。如果你这样看，有时说“抱歉，现在我要为自己选择”会更容易。灵感通常感觉像一道闪电。正如我们所见，我们可以做很多事情来让我们的思想成为创造力的好客之地。在我们这一集的配套故事中，仅供《Hidden Brain Plus》订阅者使用，
we explore the role of effort in producing inspiration that feels effortless. If you're a subscriber, that episode is available right now. It's titled, Inspiration Meets Perspiration. If you're someone who spends a lot of time scrolling social media or attending to emails and text messages during the day, please listen to this episode. It will tell you why you are selling yourself short. when it comes to being creative. If you're not yet a subscriber,
我们探讨了努力在产生感觉毫不费力的灵感中的作用。如果你是订阅者，那一集现在就可以收听了。它的标题是《灵感遇见汗水》。如果你是一个花很多时间在白天刷社交媒体或处理电子邮件和短信的人，请听这一集。它会告诉你为什么你在创造力方面看轻了自己。如果你还不是订阅者，
go to support.hiddenbrain.org. If you're using an Apple device, go to apple.com slash hidden brain. Again, that's support. com.hiddenbrain.org or apple.com slash hidden brain. Psychologist Op Dykstrahaus is the author of Inspiration,
请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。如果你使用的是苹果设备，请访问 apple.com/hiddenbrain。再说一遍，那是 support.hiddenbrain.org 或 apple.com/hiddenbrain。心理学家奥普·戴克斯特拉豪斯是《灵感：最好的想法来自哪里》一书的作者。
where the best ideas come from. Op, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you. Thank you, Shankar. Can you think of a problem you solved after being stuck for a long time? What techniques helped you unblock yourself? If you have a personal story you would be willing to share with the Hidden Brain audience or a question or comment about this episode, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone.
奥普，非常感谢你今天加入《Hidden Brain》。谢谢。谢谢，尚卡尔。你能想到一个你在被困很长时间后解决的问题吗？什么技巧帮助你解开了困局？如果你有一个愿意与《Hidden Brain》听众分享的个人故事，或者关于这一集的问题或评论，请找一个非常安静的房间，并在手机上录制一段语音备忘录。
Two or three minutes is plenty. Email the file to us at Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org using the subject line, inspiration. Again, that email address is feedback at hiddenbrain.org. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer.
两三分钟就足够了。请将文件通过电子邮件发送给我们，地址是 Feedback@Hiddenbrain.org，主题行请写“Inspiration”。再说一遍，电子邮件地址是 feedback@hiddenbrain.org。《Hidden Brain》由《Hidden Brain Media》制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。
I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you like this episode, please think of a couple of friends who would find it interesting or useful and tell them to listen to the show. If you're a parent or a teacher, consider sharing this episode with your kids or in a classroom. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是《Hidden Brain》的执行编辑。如果你喜欢这一集，请想几个会觉得它有趣或有用的朋友，并告诉他们去听这个节目。如果你是家长或老师，考虑与你的孩子或在课堂上分享这一集。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。